WE GOT A GUEST, A PROSPY,
STAYING THE NIGHT.
- I'M MIKEY, BUT ALL MY FRIENDS
AT HOME CALL ME LEGS.
- LEGS.
WHAT, ARE YOU ON THE TRACK TEAM
OR SOMETHING?
- OH, NO, NO.
CANADA CANCELLED TRACK
AFTER BEN JOHNSON SHAMED
OUR COUNTRY BY CHEATING.
[laughter]
- I GUESS WE'RE NOT USED
TO YOUR CANADIAN COMEDY.
- I GET IT, I GUESS.
[babies crying]
- MACKEREL, TRIPLETS.
THREE TIMES THE BLESSING.
- YEAH,
AT THREE TIMES THE COST.
- I ADMIRE YOUR STRENGTH.
I THOUGHT BLIND PEOPLE
WORE GLASSES.
- OH.
WELL, MY BLINDNESS WAS
A PREEXISTING CONDITION,
SO MY INSURANCE
DOESN'T COVER IT.
I HAD TO BUY THE CANE MYSELF.
- PEACE OUT.
[school bell rings]
- SO HOW ARE YOU ENJOYING
YOUR TIME HERE SO FAR?
- OH, IT'S QUITE COOL.
IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN OUR CAFETORIUM, THOUGH.
OH, HELLO.
CAN I HAVE A SOFT BOIL WITH
THE BACK BACON ON BROWN BREAD,
A SACK OF KETCHUP CHIPS,
AND, UH, A BAG OF HOMO MILK?
- [laughs]
HOMO MILK?
- YEAH, 3% HOMOGENIZED MILK.
- SO JUST GET HIM
SOME REGULAR MILK, MANNY.
- SORRY.
SORRY.
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
MANNY'LL TAKE CARE OF YOU.
- YOU KEEP YOUR MILK IN BAGS?
- YEAH.
WELL, HOW WOULD YOU STORE IT?
- WHY DON'T YOU PUT 'EM
IN CARTONS?
- BECAUSE WE KEEP IT IN A BAG.
- YOU CAN'T KEEP MILK IN A BAG.
- OH, HEY, TOONS.
WHERE'S BECCA?
- OH, SHE COULDN'T MAKE IT.
NURSING FOR THREE TAKES HOURS.
- OH, MY.
- MIND IF I JOIN YOU?
- YEAH.
- ACTUALLY, THIS TABLE'S FULL.
I'M SURE YOU'LL FIND A GOOD
PARKING SPOT, TOON-BUGGY.
- TOON-BUGGY?
- YEAH, YOU DODO BIRD.
- HEY, DARREN!
THEY GOT THE BAKED ONES.
- [laughs]